[Music]
today's question comes from rashad in
washington dc
i was wondering if there is a baby step
8 that could help listeners reach a
level of wealth in the tens of millions
and leave a legacy that can benefit our
children and grandchildren and promote
amazing generosity
well good news for a shot it exists and
it's the baby step right before it baby
step seven build wealth and give and
that can look different for a lot of
people some people that could be a
million for you i hope it's tens of
millions and i hope you leave a legacy
and you give outrageously generous and
you leave an inheritance to your
children's children as proverbs says so
absolutely uh dave this can be done and
it's some of the most inspiring parts of
this whole plan
well here's what happens
the first
five to ten million
of net worth that someone uh gets which
by the way if you have a 10 million
dollar net worth and it's producing 10
percent
that's a million dollars of your income
okay you can change your family tree and
be outrageously generous and impact your
entire community with a million dollars
a year okay
so you can get there for sure all right
the uh but but you know investing in
your 401k your home maybe a couple of
rental properties uh that's what the
typical person does in our studies of
actual millionaires in that first five
to 10 million
to go from 10 million to say a hundred
mate
which you would start to look then at uh
billionaires as an example which would
be
you know ten times a hundred million or
uh what is it one thousand million
is a billion is that right
um that's a lot of difference okay so
all of your forbes 400 for instance are
billionaires none of them became
billionaires with their 401k
or paying off their home
none of them okay they didn't become
billionaires doing that
uh they in in virtually every case owned
or operated or took public a large
company
in virtually every case oprah
uh
walmart family chick-fil-a family
uh
you know you go down the list and uh
dell
uh gates
uh
uh of course warren buffett but in every
case they they had an idea
and i know a guy who's worth several
billion um
and he makes parts for cell phones
you know but he just they but they grew
the company hugo
and took it public or didn't and made
the cash flow off of it or sold the
company
generally to go from the 10 15 million
up into the stratosphere so to speak you
truly are a one percenter then
okay
um and i mean you're a tenth of a
percenter then but it's generally you
take some of the money that you have
made and
some of it somehow grows exponentially
uh and so
you know in our case uh my net worth is
considerably more than 10 million and so
uh i mean the building we're sitting in
is uh
you know the building complex here is
worth a couple hundred million and it's
all paid for so just to give you an idea
so that's you know but did we get there
with our 401k no no i mean i've sold 25
million books i own a huge business that
makes a lot of money and helps a lot of
people and so that's that's what ends up
happening to get into that stratosphere
but the point is this the thing he's
trying to do is create a generosity
movement and if you'll start where you
are
with generosity today
and every time you make more increase
your generosity you're going to see your
opportunities increase as well and your
opportunities for i mean i remember the
first time i made ten thousand dollars
and my tithe check was a thousand
dollars
man i thought i was the most spiritual
dude on the planet i just gave a
thousand dollars me and god i'm helping
god out here to which god is laughing at
my little thousand dollar gift right you
thought you'd get an extra fuel on the
ground he's like look at that grain of
sand he thinks he's something
you know but i thought i mean i really
was proud of myself i just gave a
thousand dollars away man to the church
i am a spiritual dude giving feels good
but it does it does feel good but i was
pretty arrogant about it what i'm saying
i'm being i'm being a little too
authentic here but i really did i felt
really i mean but the first time you do
and that but the thing is get used to
doing that then get the rhythm of that
the more money you make the more money
you give the more money you make the
more money you give and constantly be
doing that and you will find yourself
starting to impact entire sectors around
you and change your family tree but ten
million dollars change your family tree
oh yeah you don't have to have a hundred
what i'm hearing is don't wait until you
go well when i have this much money then
i'll start giving give today with what
you got and you can ramp it up over time
because it's a muscle you need to build
in a rhythm because my point is first
time i gave a hundred dollars i thought
it was a lot then the first time i gave
a thousand dollars and then we had uh
what year before last we gave a million
in one day that's right remember that
that was fun around christmas time yeah
it was a blast we had so much fun doing
that so that was trippy you know and
then i thought i kind of thought i kind
of had the same thing like i just gave
away a million dollars but it wasn't
even my money it was god's money so then
i had to get over myself you know so
that kind of stuff but it's just it's a
process you know
and but the muscle built gradually over
time i didn't go from i don't give
anything to a million in one day
and so you just you build it over time
that's a beautiful question what a
beautiful spirit i love that rashaan